hello everyone and welcome to game 23 of
the 1909 match between josé raúl
capablanca and Frank James Marshall I
know what you're thinking how is this
game 23 we've only reached the game 13
well you're not the only one to be
surprised by this you might say ok the
game 13 capablanca is already in the
lead 7 to 1 against one of the top 10
players in the world Frank James
Marshall and you know that's a huge
handicap chances are Marshalls not
coming back into this match and then to
everyone's surprise
they just started drawing games and nine
games in succession were drawn so every
game from game 14 to game 22 was drawn
and since well the the way this worked
is they didn't have a patron for this
match but they also received the money
from the audience ooh it was also a
pay-per-view and and they thought that
capablanca is a stronger per player here
no doubt as he's leading 7 to 1 that
capablanca chose to draw games on
purpose even from better positions so he
would gain more money as you know if the
match lasts longer he gains more money
therefore there's no logic for him to
enter the match prematurely but then
after carefully studying the games they
decided that it was definitely not
Capablanca who was drawing on purpose if
anyone Frank Marshall was the one who
had better options in those nine games
to go perhaps to pursue something more
than a draw but Capablanca definitely
didn't you know ruin his positions on
purpose had to make the match last
longer so they so they said okay that's
a it was any interesting theory but you
know there's no merit to do it so
without further ado let's check out game
23 and also I don't know if I mentioned
this prior to this match capablanca did
not stun study any opening theory but
for this game his friends you know in
between games as this match lies that
the I believe almost two months they
showed in a showed him a couple of games
played in the match misses versus
Rubinstein where an interesting line of
the tower defense was used and
Capablanca decided to employ it against
Marshall in this game so without further
ado Marshall has the white pieces and he
opens with
d4 we have the
five c4 and East six nights to c3 and
now c5 we have the tartar defense on the
board and this is something kappa blanka
also mentions that you might have
noticed that even okay he was a much
younger than but in his match against
one course with one course so used the
much sharper openings and there it
really mattered that capablanca did not
know any opening theory because he could
easily lose the game already in the
opening here marshall goes for more of a
positional lines and this really goes
into a couple of long cast favor s he
really just wants to go straight into
the endgame but okay see capture some d5
he captures night to a three and nights
the c6 both players just keep on
developing g3 marshall prepares to
fianchetto his LightSquared Bishop
Bishop to e6 and better to g2 Bishop to
e7
we have castles Knight to f6 and now
kappa blanka says the probably the best
way for whites to keep everything you
know going is d captures on c5 and okay
the engine even agrees with capablanca
and bottom marshal was Bishop to g5 he
wants to keep on developing without
wasting time but here exactly the
opposite happens here a couple unka is
able to do this again maneuver that tres
pieces which is something Capablanca
enjoys doing very much it's similar like
the last word offense in the Queens
gambit declined where you go 9404 trade
of dark square bishop send you all also
want to snatch up this knight on c3 and
okay Bishop captures Queen captures and
now Knight to e5 the problem with D
captures on c5 now is that if Knight
captures be captures and Queen captures
you know you will have this weak bone a
weak c3 pawn and the black will have a
very comfortable game so after Queen e7
we have a 95 by Marshall and okay
Knight captures on d4 we have Knight
captures on e4 d captures on e4 and now
III kick him back the knight Knight to
f3 check and now Marshall decides to
keep his light square Bishop we have
Knight captures he captures on f3 and
Queen captures on f3 but here a couple
Blanc has simply castles as the point
this pawn cannot be captured if Queen
captures on b7 then combo Blanca can
simply trade and after rook attacks
Bishop I would either go back or if you
try something like centralizing the
Bishop and black is just gonna push it
all the way back and then you're gonna
capture on b2 you're gonna play rooks t8
put this past bone and black will have a
very nice game so after castling rook F
the c1 was played by Marshall and now
comes Luke 8 to b8 capablanca doesn't
want to start his expansion on the Queen
side too early because here Marshall
could get ideas like Queen captures on
a8 simply grabbing both rooks for the
Queen and as you still have your light
square bishop you will be able to defend
very well against black light square
bishop and it's not like you're gonna
get made it and two rooks will hold
their own against the Queen so kappa
blanka doesn't allow this first route 8
to be 8 and now Queen to e4 here
Marshall wants to trade his light square
bishop as his light square bishop
although very nicely finicky Road it's a
bit worse than Kappa Blanc has a very
strong bishop on e6 he wants to play
Bishop to h3 attack the bishop here and
Kappa longer cannot move it as his Queen
on e7 is undefended so first he moves it
Queen to c7 there is no danger of b4 as
black and simply push c4 black even
wants to push c4 as soon as possible so
this goes in in blacks favor
so after Queen c7 rook the c3 and with
ideas of either doubling up on the C
file or developing this rook to d1 b5 by
a backup of blanca now comes a 3 and C 4
and okay Bishop to f3
now again Bishop to g4 is an idea you
want to trade this Bishop 4 for blacks
very strong bishop on e6 about again
capablanca doesn't allow it
rook f d8 now if Bishop g4 it is
playable but then rush of d5 attacks the
bishop and wins this very important
diagonal so now we have rook to d1
opposing a couple Blancas very strong
rook on d8 rook captures Bishop captures
and now rook to d8 Marshall again has to
waste a move in bringing the bishop into
the game or he can simply look to see
one roof to see one would have most
likely been the matter of the two ideas
but first okay he goes for Bishop to f3
he wants to try and trade Queens with
Queen to c6 and here okay capablanca
says okay that's not a problem just g6
and
everything is fine and it was this
position that Emmanuel Lasker saw and he
said that black has now full control of
the board and this is a perfect example
of how you can use very very tiny
advantages to you know well try to
direct your your game to something more
than a draw and that here is how
Capablanca does it first Queen c6
offering that a trade of Queens and in a
couple blanket the declines even though
after captures and captures attacking
the b5 pawn you can play Bishop h3
threaten checkmate and after
why defense Roxie one you're gonna go a
six and it's still a very promising
position for black but couple monica's
idea is even better after Queen c6 he
goes Queenie five and now after Queen to
b4 he decides the trade here on e4
without him having to lose the tempo
defending the b5 pawn Queen captures we
have Bishop captures and now rook to d1
this comes with check and it's very
important Marshall wants to prevent
White King from entering the game so
King to g2 and now comes a five and okay
we have looked the c2 Marshall also has
to try and activate somehow he wants to
keep an eye on the b2 pawn so black rook
doesn't attack it but you're not gonna
be able to oppose a couple on Castro on
the open D file so first before we have
a captures a captures and now Bishop to
f3 attacking the rook and the rook the
b1 now this rook is stuck guarding this
pawn Bishop to e2 attacking the c4 pawn
twice but now comes b3 attacking the
rook and here the problem with rook the
c3 is if you play route the c3 then you
get the rook captures and after Bishop
captures here
rook see two wins the game and you're
either gonna move the rope who grabbed
the phone and then you lose the bishop
here or you're gonna try and capture the
rug button captures on c2 and the depend
upon Queens on a dark square the light
square bishop is helpless against the
guarding this square so even the you
know the interface shows the the hunter
Bishop moving as a knight but this is
not possible of course after be three we
have ripped the d2 and now comes
look the see one here a couple blanca
prepares c3 and now there really isn't
anything white can do here
Bishop to d1 was played but now c3 pawn
captures on c3 and now b2 now you have
to give up you have to capture with the
rook and give up the bishop on d1 route
capture some video was played rook
captures on d1 and now comes look to see
to at least White has two points for his
piece so he can maybe try pushing in the
C pawn bishop to f5 kicking the rook
away from this C file rugby - and now
comes Luke the c1 of course you wanna
marshal try putting his rook behind the
past pawn now couple uncle DAWs put his
robe behind a passed pawn as that's
where you usually want to put your looks
behind passed pawns
we have roped the b3 defending the pawn
on c3 and now Bishop to b4 check King h3
and now rook rook rook to c2 attacking
the f2 pawn we have F for defending the
pawn now the king guards the h2 pawn and
now comes h5 here a couple Blanca is
threatening Bishop to a5 check for
example if you tried something like rook
to a3 just repeating moves and hoping
you have some sort of a fortress it
doesn't work because Bishop f5 check
King gage for now rook captures on h2
you start losing material King g5 and
then in g7 you're threatening checkmate
with f6
White has to prevent this you have to
pin the pawn either with rook to a 7 or
or even roof to a6 defending the DF 6
square a butter still I have to loop to
h3 you're gonna attack the pawn and the
White has no moves after c4 you're just
gonna capture this after King moves
rookies recheck King moves and now
you're just gonna waste a pawn here
after c5 which is gonna give a check
after King captures now you've got
you've gotten rid of your phone and
after roguish rechecking d5 Luke h5
checkmate it's just one of the lines
that shows how dangerous this position
is so you can't really allow this so we
have g4
you have to sacrifice some material to
survive checkmate H captures on g4 we
have King capture son g4 and now rook
captures on h2
rook the B for attacking couple on
commission but now at 5 with check
kingi three and now rook to e2 there's
no way to defend your III pawn so rook
the c-4 is played with rook captures on
e3 at least now the c3 pawn is defended
King to h4 and now King g7 roped the c7
check we have King to f6 now threatening
some very nice checkmating ideas rook to
d7 but now comes Bishop to g2 and now
the h2 square dh3 square is covered rook
to h3 is the threat of checkmate and it
there's very little you can do here rook
to d6 was played by marshal couple
months I played King to g7 and it was in
this position that Frank James Marshall
resigned the game after after 23 games a
lot of venues and I believe almost two
months of gameplay kappa blanka wins the
match 8 to 1 this is a unimaginable
no one has defeated a top 10 player with
such a score in those days it was a you
know like I said unimaginable why did
you resign well if you keep on checking
King comes to h6 and now there's really
no way to prevent whatever you play you
can you know wait some material and
there are no chances for you to to
achieve some sort of a trick by
sacrificing you look or something as you
still have your pawn and after any move
rook age 3 will be checkmate so yeah a
very tough match for Frank James
Marshall who like we already mentioned
this was basically after the death of
hairiness and Pillsbury in 1906 this
match was supposed to confirm that
Marshall is the strongest player in the
United States and that he will after
this match receive the title of US
Champion but here after this match was
finished
Marshall protested to the official
arbiter the official arbiter was a
Waltrip and Shipley he was a lawyer but
also a painter a patron and the chief
arbiter of this match this is the
gentleman here also a very strong player
himself he he managed to draw a draw
some games against Harry Nelson
Pillsbury also he defeated both Williams
Chinese and Emmanuel asker in
simultaneous exhibitions so definitely
not you know
a beginner or anything and he decided
that okay since Capablanca is Cuban he
cannot be a u.s. champion he does not
have a US citizenship but neither can
but you know Marshall will not be a US
Champion either so what mr. Walter been
simply decided is that Jackson whoops
Showalter it's this gentleman he was the
person who held the title of US Champion
before Harry Nelson Pillsbury won it
from him and that the title of US
Champion now goes back to him even
though he's a retired chess player but
regardless he never lost the match other
than to Harry Nelson Pillsbury who is
now dead
and he never backed down from a
challenge so until he loses a match to
someone or you know forfeits or doesn't
you know I want to play then someone
else can become US Champion and okay
later in 1909 marshal Frank James
Marshall did challenge mr. Showalter and
he won the match against him and he
became the United States Champion okay a
couple Blancas went back to cuba it was
a six-week trip and when he finally went
back to Havana they asked him that they
heard that he applied for the US
citizenship and that he was kind of
trying to claim the title of US Champion
but here I don't want to say anything
wrong so I do have it here this is from
the American chess Bulletin as a States
as quoted this is what capablanca says
said to them since my return to this
country a few days ago I have been asked
several times concerning my attitude
with respect to the United States
Championship and my citizenship in reply
I wish to make known my attitude in this
respect I am the undisputed champion of
Cuba at and last spring I beat Marshall
by the score of eight to one mr.
Marshall has the greatest reputation and
the best score in tournaments of any
living chess player in the USA and is
therefore considered everywhere as the
strongest representative of the United
States by my victory over Marshall I
have taken his position
the strongest representative on this
side of the Atlantic therefore I
consider myself the champion of America
and stand ready to defend my title
within a year against any American of
the United States of America or anywhere
else for a side bet of at least $1,000
in those days that was a lot of money
United States currency under these
circumstances the question whether I am
a citizen of the United States of
America or not has nothing to do with
the matter under consideration so by
saying this Capablanca basically said
that he is the strongest player of the
indie America and that Marshall can have
his US US Championship title but you
know Capablanca is still a much stronger
player and the marshal did not take this
you know the wrong way or anything as it
was Marshall who will be endorsing
Capablanca as well a couple monkey
already mentioned that we are going to
an X tournament we're going to cover is
the 1911 tournament of San Sebastian
cappelen cast first big international
tournament but he he did not qualify for
the tournament but it was actually Frank
James Marshall who helped him enter this
tournament because you could not you
know play in that tournament without an
invitation and in that tournament only
the most elite players were invited and
Frank James Marshall made it happen and
then there were again conspiracy
theorists that said that josé raúl
capablanca and Frank James Marshall had
a secret deal where capablanca said that
he will never again try to compete for
the title of United States Champion and
that Marshall will help him you know get
invited to this prestigious event and as
Marshall was not interested in playing
there himself you know it's it's
basically a win win but there is no
proof to any any of this I just thought
you might want to know you know what the
word around was swam that's the game 23
of their match I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed the entire
coverage of the match and the entire
Capablanca saga so far next the video
were starting the son Sebastian series
truly an amazing tournament with a lot
of a lot of strong players
feel free to google it - just get in the
spirit of the event for for the next
video we're going to cover is it gonna
be it's gonna be really wild yeah I
would like to thank Blake Kirk John
Kelly
Oscar Cabrera Stefan Burke and the
denominator is for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more interesting content hopefully
sorry about no video yesterday I decided
to take a day off I don't you I don't
often do this but I really didn't feel
like making one yesterday so I thought I
better take a day off I think y'all and
I will see you soon